super popular among these top players i
kind of hope now we'll see the oh
yeah
are they listening to our show and each
geary anisha's been watching your chest
of course simon clearly goals yeah and
yeah this is another maybe a good
strategy against the younger players you
don't want to memorize reams and dreams
of theory you don't want to have to be
too direct you just want to get a
position against them and here we go
another good point behind the english
opening is white's knight has a perfect
square now behind this pawn just
pointing towards the center not
occupying the center as we talked about
in that video earlier and uh okay the
black bishop coming out putting some
pressure on white tonight and white's
queen
another good point behind the english
opening it has a nice safe square to sit
on early in the game and uh the players
moving very fast now we see a trade of
bishop for night maybe a small gain for
white there but black does have a very
strong formation in the center
and simon you talked about the iron
english what makes it so strong and uh
iron like this type of position is this
uh a position you covered in your course
um i actually give a different setup for
white um i think when you're trying to
learn an opening and this is
particularly for club players um players
who are just learning something new it
makes it a lot easier if you can play
the same kind of setup time and time
again so you don't have to learn many
different variable ways you know the
position turns into
so i recommend to set up the bottenic
played when he became world champion and
he made famous but also set up the
magnus carlsen plays regularly or has
done over the last five years and many
other uh players which controls the
light squares
the line that anisha is playing here um
is also a very common line and he's got
the two bishops you can see even this
move
that uh that anish has just played
it kind of looks looks a little bit
strange
um yeah i mean i i i think this is all
very normal very very very normal
because again white's got the two
bishops and you want to develop your
bishops so i think anish is just
thinking where is my dark square bishop
best placed and he's just aiming to fee
and shatter it um and this move is very
double edged from prague because in one
in one way you're attacking the knight
you're you're gaining tempo but the
other way look at the dart squares
you're opening up the dark squares now
are really really weak and you don't
have a dark square bishop as black to
cover them maybe we can show that david
just on the analysis board or on the
main board there so for example if black
okay he doesn't castle he takes off this
knight which was actually just sitting
on the edge of the board very surprising
decision we're going to see two bishops
against two knights yet again but for
example if black had castled now the
bishop and queen line up as you
mentioned simon this black pawn now in
the center looks like it's overextended
it wishes it could kind of push back
pawns don't move backwards unfortunately
but if it could move back and block this
diagonal because actually checkmating
ideas are on the board the whole time
but in the current position we've just
seen bishop takes knight and the fact
that anishgiri is thinking means he
might not play the most obvious queen
takes bishop instead he might
willingly ruin his own pawn structure he
has indeed done this he's given himself
doubled h pawns but yes these pawns are
ugly
at the uh kind of as compensation for
this he has opened up his rook a really
nice line now for the white rook i think
it would be almost suicidal for black to
castle on the king side because suddenly
the white rook will slide across hitting
the black king suddenly the bishop will
move across for example in this position
and everything is pointing towards this
one square
all of the heavy pieces and black's king
i think
it's just going to be doomed long term
there's no way you can really hold this
together um unless you're super brave
and
kind of really ingenious with your
solutions but i think in this current
position um castling would be a
practical mistake uh i it would make
more sense to me if black maybe starts
developing his knight his queen first
and maybe even trying to shift his king
in the opposite direction shift the king
to the queen side
to me this looks like a crazy position
you know the bishop against the two
knights pawn structure is like random
it's quite it's quite funny because when
you know we were both juniors around the
same time was with similar ages and
when i was a junior i was playing the
english opening all the time yeah so
this is like when i was eight nine ten
whatever and all my peers you know
they'd always be playing e4 opening and
be like you're so boring you're playing
english opening the english is such a
boring opening how can you play that
you're an old man before your time and
um you know it it is actually as we can
see from this position here a very
fascinating opening and the e4 in some
respects is much more boring especially
at top level because you have many uh
drawish lines there in the english you
don't have those lines so uh so i didn't
don't listen to what other people say
just do it anyway don't listen to them
um where simon and i both played each
other when we were very young like maybe
eight or nine years old
and uh when he played the english
against me that was the very first time
i faced that opening oh i was like
what is this no one picks up that pawn
and so i was like okay and i just made
up something there
lost my queen
no no no it was a game where i lost my
queen and then i thought to myself and
you were like he was like i'm gonna win
and i was like i don't what i don't
wanna i don't wanna lose
i had a request in return for the queen
and now i won one pawn and then i won
another pawn and then you offered me a
draw and i was like yeah i'll have that
so the first time you guys played the
english it was a draw yeah sorry
is it
well these games what how would you
describe the english games are they
fighting are they solid
that's the beauty of it i think the
english opening it suits all kinds of
styles if you want to be solid with
white you can be but i mean if you're in
a fighting mood like anish giri right
here you can completely balance the
position you can open up lions whites
queens and bishops can fly out um
yeah the english opening has a lot of
potential and likewise for black as
cevanko says you can kind of freestyle
in a way you can pretty much do anything
as black and you will be okayish but uh
yeah here i mean this position
it's actually quite funny because we
looked at the game between ding and
jordan van freest and that game was two
bishops against two knights and white
also had doubled h pawns
and we've got the same again um but
meanwhile big moment for pregnant
again don't castle towards the king side
it's also interesting to see the
valuation bar i know it's not maybe a
very strong evaluation bar but it does
seem to favor uh prague's position which
which i find a little bit a little bit
surprising um i i just i just love this
dark square bishop yeah you can never
exchange that bishop off as black and
it's on a beautiful diagonal but maybe i
i'm you know relying too much on just
one piece um you know if one piece is
going to win the game i could see that
bishop certainly being that piece uh but
i think i'd still take white here um
personally i mean just you know the one
with the attacking chances yeah for now
at least me and uh the only issue is
what's white gonna do with the king i
mean yeah i can move to the left side of
the board but you know it's not
especially safe there but you know
because of the dark square bishop it's
it provides it's like both a good
defensive and attacking piece and uh
well you'll be relieved to see that uh
pragnanda listened to david although
they can't really hear us dating
but there was some kind of like
subliminal messaging going on and you
know he listened and he understood
there's no way do you ever have that
talk about spending more messages
sometimes when i'm playing i think you
can actually now this might sound a bit
weird but um when you're sitting there
for like seven hours you can kind of get
into your opponent's mind and then get
into yours and sometimes even if they
play a really odd move you can kind of
you kind of expect that move and it's
weird it's like this move you just think
they're gonna play this move even though
you know it's a weird movie and then
they play and it's like how did that
work out you know it's like some kind of
some kind of mind power going on i don't
know was that just me being a bit weird
no no i could be psychic maybe well i
don't know maybe it's cycling weird yeah
but i don't know do you ever have
because i have that quite often i mean
one of the things that i get with
especially
asking for our quiz of the day about
opening struggles is that you know i've
analyzed this position i've thought
about everything and then when i get to
the board i'm like what happens if they
play this move and sure
that you've analyzed they've kind of
honed in on that one that you're like
does that happen to you david all the
time all the time there you go so it's
not just me good job
but uh meanwhile we have had a couple of
moves and maybe these two players are
psychic as well because they've both
copied each other they've both castled
their kings over to the queen side so uh
no big attacks yet both kings are
maybe targets long term but for now it's
all about mobilizing white bishops or
mobilizing the black knights
and i've got to say the more i look at
it the more i think
yes the bishops have potential but
blacks knights for now have the clearer
path towards good squares
okay very good strategy first of all
from gary if you castle on what we call
the long side on the queen side always
always take another move to shuffle your
king towards the corner it's just safer
in the corner and
copycat again the psychic bond has not
been broken they're both copying each
other's moves yep always shuffle your
king towards the corner because you
protect more squares that way um it's
easier to hide simply
and uh yeah still very kind of weird
imbalanced position
but the computer thinks level chances
for now and both of these players
played a draw in the first round in
chessable masters we can take a look at
the results from round one we did have
three players who were able to
win their games sam shanklin won against
gwayne jones david anton he won the
first game against 13 year old abby
monumishra and as we saw dingley ran
winning game one against jordan found
for east a crazy game right there all
the other games ended with jules anish
geary he played a draw against nels
grandelias and pragnanda a draw against
so in this one well we have a winner the
bard just went over to prague's uh side
in an exciting game with the english
opening yeah i mean i like white's last
move uh shuffling the king right into
the corner but the evaluation evaluation
bar hates it so
it's one of those positions it's just so
imbalanced right i would be surprised if
we do see a draw in this one somehow
it feels like either the white bishops
are going to take over and dominate
later on or the black knights will just
be tricky and like we saw in the ding
game maybe the knights will
somehow create a mating net later
once things kind of clarify it but i
think it's going to open up at some
point i mean at the moment it's a little
bit cagey but at some point they're
going to have to open the position well
i say open open the position would only
be good for whites really because the
two bishops i mean
you could if i was white here i'd be
trying to get the light squared bishop
on the other diagonal and try to open it
up maybe we can show that uh very
quickly uh on the board it seems like a
very very normal thing to do just trying
to get my piece that's undeveloped
pointing towards black's king and i'd
use a little pawn lever
in the middle to try and get rid of the
one pawn that annoys me a little bit is
black's pawn in the middle of the board
so i'd want to try to move that pawn by
pushing pushing a pawn in front of rook
and just trying to get rid of that one i
mean this seems like a very simple way
to play if i get rid of that pawn the
light square bishop comes to life as
well points over and this seems like
just a normal way to develop the game so
glad you said the word normal because
this was also my first instinct but then
i had a little bit more of a creative
instinct which is actually
to kind of be a bit brutal current
position yeah and the current position
is actually to retreat the queen one
step onto the light square okay so for
example here yeah and then the whole
idea is actually to step forward with
the rook two squares
and
have some fun on the third row i like it
swinging across you're getting back into
the swinging again juventus yeah we've
told you about that swinging
oh yeah
yeah just say no you'll be i've learned
from set of times just say no you don't
have to you don't have to enter into the
joke
really creative though yeah i like it
yes yeah yeah
it's it's very caveman style you know
but i was kind of because i was a bit
frustrated by the fact that you know
stepping forward the bishop blocks in
the rook um so yeah
this is an
abnormal way to play this cave women
yeah maybe you can combine them all and
uh yep instead of planting this bishop
here first ivanka's idea here if black
just waits it's actually hard to see
what black does for example brings a
knight into the center now you lift your
rook up and only then do you bring the
bishop to the long diagonal once your
rook's out of the way and yeah i mean
it's uh it's such a nice fact
i really like it as well i mean you see
where your opponent puts the king and
you simply aim all your pieces at your
opponent's king i mean it's uh it's a
nice way to play my arrows there so yeah
but aiming towards the black king yeah
yeah yeah it's interesting very very
interesting and we can see pragnanda
he's just thinking it's a very tense
position and it's not exactly clear what
i think both sides are doing especially
for pragnando who perhaps has to wait a
little bit more but whilst he's thinking
well we do have two competitions we have
a selfie competition where this
fantastic goodie bag is up for grabs
everything's signed by anish giri yeah
and does that increase the price or
lower it
just wondering for a friend
you and a niche battling over having the
most chestable courses
and we see pragnanda actually stepping
forward with his queen's bishop porn and
uh well
just uh share with you some selfies and
the first one is from marco frenias who
says big hello to everyone in studio and
is sending us all the greetings from
croatia and kaia you asked for a cool
selfie and here it is that's what i got
very cool marco and uh inga leicher
larsen uh says watching the chess on
youtube to this view and take a look at
this view wow all i needed to boost my
motivation for school is arendelle such
a beautiful place wow so that's where
the nice weather in norway is because
it's definitely not in oslo yeah it's
where the champions train don't they
mester's mester scope aha
and uh yeah so we should head back to
the board because there's been a few
changes
yeah so prague actually really taking
risks now because he pushed forward with
the black pawn quite near the black king
and anisha said okay i'll happily trade
here and we talked about the rooks
pointing towards kings
white's rook now on this left side of
the board
on d-file can slide across opposite
black's king and
we might see a bit of uh mirror image
here in the position um anish just
following a typical uh plan but a
consistent plan for example okay white
has just taken a pawn here if black
recaptures with his pawn i think maybe
he should take with his knight just to
activate but suddenly we see the white
rook slide across opposite the black
king okay he does take with his knight
and here we would have seen a scenario
where maybe
for example okay just uh just to show um
we could see the white bishops both
pointing on the long diagonals and the
white rooks both kind of supporting
behind and uh i think white has too much
central control there so instead black
does get active this must have been
prague's idea normally when you're
facing
uh the bishop pair the two bishops you
should try and speed things up
accelerate the play before the ships
take control and maybe his idea is to
jump to the side of the board here
attacking white's queen and attacking
white's bishop
um so hey does anish have to stop this
threat maybe of the knight coming and
attacking the queen
and he does stop it by bringing his
queen
to the side of the board but out of the
way of his bishop now his bishop simon
said that this bishop is going to win
the game for white so maybe this bishop
on this long diagonal now
is going to create some nuisance and
watch out for this idea later the white
rook swinging across to the black king
all right the bar now roughly to the
middle ivanka did mention the selfie
competition we have where the prize is
designed goody bag by anish geary and
then we also have that other
competition going on the question of
today where you can win a chessable
course valued at
300 dollars and the question is
what you struggle with the most in the
opening that's what we want to know
that's what we want to know and it's a
fantastic prize up for grabs uh of
course on the queen's gambit declined by
alex
and uh yep so we do have a move from
pragnanda he's retreated his knight
getting ready to centralize or maybe
even to move it to the left side of the
board just to protect the king so after
all knight is the king's best friend as
we've learned from david and uh well a
lot of people being very honest with
their struggles oh yeah and i i have to
say i feel a lot of empathy for these
struggles con kernin lyrica says
our interns struggle the most to not
play the london
i have to say as a londoner and i and
someone who does play the london system
as a hobby i uh i also sometimes have
that urge
to play a london system
every opening that gets the most hate
the london system really every meme i
see online is about how much people hate
the london systems so it's basically a
bad opening no it's a great it's a great
opening but from black it's very
annoying because you can't create many
winning chances
it's annoying to face i have to say i
was preparing for someone um and his
specialty was the london system and you
know everything seemed to be slightly
better for white and i was just like oh
come on whenever i look at the london
system with white everything seems to be
equal why is it like that
so the london system it's not the most
winning opening i guess then no unless
your name is magnus carson he seems to
win every time he touches the london
system yeah but in this game we had the
english opening and the winner of
today's question of today will then win
that course on the queen's gambit
decline then after this game we're going
to deep dive into the queen's gambit
declined which we now know is the second
most popular opening on the meltdown to
champions chester among these top
players and after this game we're going
to deep dive into it the history of that
fantastic and very popular opening
yeah meanwhile a few changes on the
board the position has slightly opened
up simon are you happy to see black
central porn has been traded off
yeah i think i'd be feeling a bit more
comfortable if i was white here i mean i
was feeling pretty comfortable anyway
but um i think uh generally the more
open the position comes the better the
bishops become um on the positive side
blacks i mean that another danger you
got when you're playing with knights as
black is here prague
they can often be pushed back pushed
away by your opponent's pawns it's quite
hard to stabilize them and this is just
a real problem knights against bishops
it's not always the bishops are better
it's that the pawns come forwards and
they just push those knights back and
in the long run this seems to be a
problem with the black knights they're
not stable both of those black knights
are not on squares where they can remain
for the rest of the game uh i don't know
i don't think white should push the pawn
in in the middle quite yet but at some
point
it just seems like they're going to get
pushed around and you combine this with
the bishops the rooks the open lines it
just seems very pleasant for white and i
i certainly
think the niche is doing very well at
the moment yeah also white's king is
nicely tucked away uh the black king
potentially a bit vulnerable and uh i
guess the question uh my next question
just before we go back to the players is
does white take this pawn can you get
away with taking it with your bishop or
with your rook i don't think you should
take with a bishop because uh if you do
get greedy and capture then suddenly
this pawn push will release another
attack against this bishop and look it's
suddenly pinned this is a pin if the
bishop moves the rook behind it will
fall but
it's slightly tempting to go and grab
this pawn with your rook and after this
trade you don't have the same problem
with this bishop getting trapped because
if black does push forward with this
pawn you can maybe just grab uh you just
get greedy and i never considered that i
never considered you taking the report
and think about it i thought no other
side of the board yeah i just didn't
even look at it i thought
we'd just get on with it you know
against the king
david
straight away grab that pawn i've been
looking at it for a few moments already
simon yeah what if you can grab the pawn
why not you know it's a pawn is a pawn
he doesn't oh
okay
very quickly so the only only reason i
didn't like this straight away is i
thought black could temporarily put the
knight on the side of the board but i
guess white's idea is to retreat that
bishop um which i've only just seen
could be a very good option but it's
black blacks knights they just seem very
unstable don't they and
i mean maybe black's fine but i wouldn't
like to be in his shoes at the moment
they could be very very bad but they
could also be decent and tricky pieces
later so
yeah let's go back to the players it's
still really in the balance right now
and uh can i just bring your attention
to something else look at the bar in the
game between the youngest grandmaster in
the world i'll be manu mishra and world
number two
dingley rand the bar is all the way over
to our bim on your mishra's side
okay it's very tense but it does look
good for him so uh
okay early early days in that one he's
got a big advantage after the opening
it's just about whether he can convert
it will nerves get in the way will ding
be able to fight back wait how big of a
shock would that be so last season
mitchell won one game in that one
tournament he played against pentala
harry krishna it was a huge shock it was
just an amazing performance now he's
playing world number two
that would be a step up
an even bigger shock for sure he's just
got to beat magnus next isn't he and
it'd be yeah we're all done see all
right so he'll break the record
of fernanda yeah he'll be the youngest
player ever to defeat a world champion
yeah
if he beats magnus
which is uh
and would be incredible achievement i
mean he beat the record by three and a
half years or something at this point uh
mishra
yeah incredible so still early days in
that game uh just keep an eye on it
please and that we will definitely jump
over if mishra is about to win that game
a lot of hard work to be done okay in
the meantime and do remember if you are
watching us on twitch you can in the
control center actually design your own
uh screen and you can have up as many
games as you want you can follow both
this and you can follow the studio you
can follow for example that game between
mishra and ding
if you are following us on twitch all
right then on the move the bar is
swinging from side to side yeah and it's
similar to what simon pointed out it's
all about whether those two black
knights on the side of the board are
they a strength or are they just kind of
locked down to each other immobilized um
are they just kind of bystanders while
the real action happens
pregnant and are now meanwhile trying to
improve his rook he's eyeing up white's
central pawns which
are slightly loose i guess that's why
you hesitated earlier simon from pushing
those white pawns because it does feel a
bit loose for white but
no direct threat for black yet blacks
knights can't move even to go and grab
pawns because they have to protect each
other
it's just about well how anishigiri
improves his pieces maybe it's time to
move one of the bishops move one of the
white rooks
still so tense and uh i mean this this
is the type of position which could
swing all the way in black's favor could
swing all the way in white's favor
um clock times it's
still in the balance as well
i feel the decisive result in this game
i would be
i would bet like okay i'm not a gambling
man but i would be very surprised if it
wasn't a draw yeah i have if it was a
draw yeah i have to say i i really do
like anish's position but
there it comes with a caveat i do think
that he has to consolidate so you know
there's porn under fire i think he has
to take on a move by move basis to fan
the pawn that's like well maybe it's not
it's not under fire what am i talking
about there's two knights that you were
mentioning um well they're kind of
tangled up with each other so
yeah i wonder if white can try to put
the rook next to the oh what's this
movie
not this one
i thought about putting the rook there
and trying to you know push those
knights away not the king yeah he's i
mean it kind of makes some sense to get
it off the the diagonal of the queen but
i don't know it's very strange this is
like like styles where all our styles
come into question i was just thinking
of over protecting all those pawns
going into defensive mode and maybe
winning on the counter-attack simon was
thinking of the attack and uh anish was
uh whoa leaving his king but i don't
understand what the plan is and here
okay we do see the stockfish suggestions
in terms of moves right now and
two moves keep the balance for black the
first move is just incredible and if
prague sees it
i'm just gonna applaud him because it's
an amazing move bringing black's knight
into the center we'll show that in a
moment but if black doesn't find the top
two moves he might be in trouble
everything else gives white a big
advantage over plus one so okay let's
jump in to show these moves on the board
um the second best move which is also
fine is to just move the rook improving
a piece this one is possible to find
maybe you want to stack up your other
rook behind it but the top move for
black is to actually give up a knight
plant the knight in the center of the
board where it looks like it can just be
taken for free white's porn can just
grab this knight but if you take it
suddenly white loses on the spot because
of this night fork this is a track
hitting white's rook and white will lose
material for example if you move towards
your rook to try and defend it then
black's knight actually jumps out the
way
discovered check and hitting the queen
you win the queen on the next go so this
is a deep tactic you have to see two or
three moves ahead um but the whole idea
is to open up this line from the black
rook and to do that you bring your
knight into the center the secondary
trick is that white's queen can't go and
take this knight because suddenly
another night fork this is why we say
knights are so tricky this is what we
call a royal fork hitting the king
hitting the queen and hitting the rook
that's just greedy and uh actually here
suddenly the momentum might well change
if black finds this move jumping into
the center will you find it i think so i
think i mean i absolutely think so
because he's gonna do it yeah because
you know it's it's a forward move you
know backward moves on the night moves
are really difficult to spot here it's
about going forward you're naturally
looking towards those checks oh he
doesn't find it and yep well it's
difficult yeah it was difficult it was
tricky but i mean this move is probably
just as good according to stockfish just
just bringing the rook up trying to get
the other rook in you're bringing all
your pieces of good squares and
playing some moves i'm trying to just
wonder what anisha's idea with his his
king over was because uh
as as you said you want to improve your
position
how does moving the king there actually
improve it i'm wondering i don't i don't
know he wanted to get it out of the eye
line of the black queen but he's now
within range of the black knights the
black knights are just one move away
from checking so okay despite the
evaluation by going up in white's favor
slightly there
i don't trust it white's position feels
so shaky and
okay both players they're getting lower
on the clock this is the type of
position which could just fall apart
suddenly for white in one move if he's
not careful as we showed there this idea
as well is still in the position
of the black knight jumping into the
center maybe it's even more powerful now
for example if you do get time to jump
into the center you still have this idea
with a check and you also have some
checks with the black rook so really
scary now for any giri he needs to
implement her pieces i mean these guys
need to join the battle i would have
thought anish should maybe just over
defend as yuvanka said now but a rook
just swing the rook to behind the pawn
defend this one and try to get your last
piece out the bishop maybe get the other
rook in the game i'm just trying to
coordinate all my pieces it's very
important to do so uh get that
coordination with your with your bits
and bobs
um and at some point i'd love to attack
that black knight on the side of the
board i mean that could be black's
weakness you know that achilles heel
black's knight um
right on the side so yeah but these
knights are forced to protect each other
so maybe uh as you mentioned that simon
if the rook does slide across maybe you
do kind of create this threat for
example black moves the rook of kicking
this knight
the kind of protector kick away the
protector and then once it moves now you
can win the piece it defended
because suddenly there's no more night
check you have guarded that square with
your rook
um so maybe a bit of a threat there
maybe that's why black missed his
opportunity to jump in but we'll see and
he
if he doesn't play this move i think
there's going to be tricks against the
white king
let's go back to the players it's
getting really
really uh complex now really rich
position though this is kind of an
advert for the english opening if you
just want to enjoy your chess not
memorize
loads of moves okay he brings his bishop
forward
maybe a similar idea uh trying to
coordinate if he brings a rook over next
move um i mean it makes some sense to
develop i feel
i was worried about this uh black knight
jumping into the center again but again
it doesn't work this time i think it
doesn't work because white's rooks
protect each other white can just start
grabbing pieces
so maybe prague has missed a small
opportunity and you're right simon if
the black root comes across
everything's at least defended now for
white
the black knights stuck we call these
superfluous nights where one is kind of
irrelevant they're both fighting for the
same square and we're also where they're
just stuck protecting each other in two
nights
so prague yeah i'm worried for his uh
chances now he's missed that one
one shot and he's down to three minutes
and he's up on five
um yeah still
it's just gonna happen yeah it's not
easy and somehow you feel that you know
because of why it's open king that black
should be looking out so maybe giving up
a rook in exchange for a bishop just to
kind of get a white's king and i think
the idea is on the board but okay anish
has gone into safety mode and protected
his one vulnerable spot the c4 pawn
and how to continue
with the black pieces not easy at all
yes
maybe white can even double up on the c
file with the rooks before doing
anything because you know just try to
bring everything around the white king
and then you've got this this pawn break
haven't you david pointed out this pawn
break to us you know to unstabilize uh
black's night at the right moment so uh
oh well this this this is a little bit
strange i mean that looks very slow i
mean that's really calm isn't it i mean
really really calm that move
uh but you're such a good positional
player pregnant that's the very
positional move but this is a tactical
position yeah um so taking a time out to
just improve a pawn
feels a bit slow and that's why the
evaluation bars have reacted all the way
on white side well can you can you play
the move straight away
i mean push the pawn forward attack the
knight is this a big blunder from
pragnanda potentially we talked about
these knights stuck defending each other
and maybe now white can push forward and
kick away
as we called it the defender the
guardian of the other knight and after a
trade of pawns for example we see that
this pawn is protected three times so
black can't really go and take it if you
take it you just lose a piece after the
white rook recaptures it's defended
sufficiently white has an extra piece
here and if you can't take it in this
position
what do you do it's the idea to jump
into the center with the knight again
but now for example queen takes knight
this is the same tactic remember hitting
the king hitting the queen that we saw
earlier but after the rook recaptures
this night now we see a position where
um
wherever white puts this bishop for
example we see two bishops against just
one rook
and that's a decisive material advantage
for white
so we could well see anish giri in
charge in control of this game if he
plays this movement
it's not difficult is it no it's
everything he's uh played before has
been building up to this moment you know
moving that king off the long diagonal
well he obviously had this poor move
planned so it's just now about
calculation and just to work out there's
no tricks and we don't see anything
white's king seems to be pretty safe
yeah the king is super safe yeah i mean
you've got to take your chance at some
point have you in when you're playing
chess even if you that's the thing with
the english opening again you know i
mentioned that a lot of people would say
when i was younger well he's played this
move which uh which i did mention was
also very tempting but it's a real
safety first move isn't it you you've
got to take your opportunities while
they're there maybe it's very strong
yeah same idea not really sure what
black can do but i mean the thing about
playing the english opening is you start
the game quite calmly that doesn't mean
it's boring you're keeping all the
pieces on and something will come to
life at some point in nearly any game of
chess really you know you don't have to
always force the fireworks you know they
will they will always happen at some
point yeah yeah i was smiling and
laughing a little bit but not because of
what simon was saying it's because this
is exactly what i say about the caracon
it doesn't have to start off with
fireworks
you can be dull at the beginning and the
fun will happen eventually
it can be yeah okay yeah i'll be honest
i'm really using the words and twisting
them today
sorry about that
it's fine
yeah no i don't mean it i mean the
caricom's very exciting it can be
there's a lot of stuff there's a lot of
opening snobs out there who judge other
openings like the london system the
carousel they're right i like that i can
imagine like opening snobs right that's
a really good turn a lot of openings out
there they think that their opening is
the best and nothing else exists but
computers have shown chessable have
shown every opening is playable if you
know them well enough
you need to work on them you need to
know your kind of ins and outs all the
little details but 100 agree and i think
opening snobs
oh you can't play that opening it's
rubbish my opening's better because uh
you know i've played it all my life
you know i've played it since yeah when
i was a young man in the war and i've
been playing this opening and how dare
you come along my blooming london system
is fantastic
opening snobs i like it yeah there are
you're totally right though you've got
to you've got to have an open mind
haven't you the top level they're all
very open-minded that's why you see
magnus he plays so many openings which
are considered dodgy and some of them
are dodgy but uh he's open-minded and
that's the only way you learn about
chess and obviously because it's the
psychological thing as well right
surprising in the opening could be a
good idea but do the computers and maybe
now especially with ai being a big part
of chess openings do they have favorite
openings openings they consider much
better well they've been trained because
you know if they play the mainstream
openings it probably will just fizzle
out into a draw so they've kind of been
trained to play these dubious openings
and you see them just uh
breathing new life into the variation
and i'd have to go through
this thing
this is crazy absolutely
okay we just missed a couple of moves
there but black has given up a night i
don't know whether this is out of
desperation or necessity but pregnant
has given up a knight and now he's gone
to attack the white queen and stockfish
here the computer we can see the three
top moves
three moves give white an advantage but
the best move
gives up the white queen and sacrificing
the white queen okay he does it but in a
different way that's the third best move
according to stockfish and here we see a
crazy position still after this rook is
captured white is going to have a rook
and two bishops in exchange for the
black queen a rook and two bishops are
definitely better than one queen alone
if they can coordinate but the white
king is a bit open so it's not game over
yet
well what do you think simon
yeah i really like it but i am surprised
that anish didn't take the other rook
maybe we can show that quickly because
you can see here the black king has two
pawns guarding it and if we dive into
the other option which is quite critical
and niche had three four minutes he
could have taken the other piece and
let's just show that on the board and
the difference of this well you get you
get very similar exchange pieces but now
look at the black king the black king is
much more
naked there it's much better i mean it
needs uh you know it's like prince
prince william without any clothes on
he's the king put some clothes on prince
william you know you're naked there so
this would have been a better option
clearly i think to go for this but uh
two bishops on a rook brook works very
well uh with the the bishop so it must
be an issue still well in charge yeah so
he's in control as long as he takes
contr uh kind of care of his own king
so now his rook is attacked i'm
expecting him to just move it forward
and he would love to combine the two
rooks and kind of go up to the top of
the board and checkmate this black king
the fact that uh the kind of rook and
two bishops are kind of numerically
worth more than the black queen that's
one thing but also three potential
attackers
black only has a queen to defend only
one potential defender and uh for
example if black gives a check himself
the white king is very very safe
actually in the corner of the board and
there's no way for the black queen to
kind of creep in and check it
everything's protected and i'm expecting
anish to just kind of line up his two
rooks and go for the attack himself as
simon said he had a better option
a much better option actually i think
aesthetically objectively but
right now he's still in control and he
has indeed put his rook on the square
maybe owing up this pawn in the center
as well it's giri's position to lose
right now
a couple of results have come in wei yi
has won his game against hari krishna a
good result for the chinese in his very
first tournament on the tour it's a draw
between vedic and gawain jones we are
keeping an eye on mishra against dingley
wren because the bar is still liking it
for the 13 year old the bar is also
liking it for eric hansen in his fight
against one of the top players in the
world you wouldn't farm for east with
the black pieces that can be an
incredible result for the canadian
but in this one anish giri with a lot
more time on the clock as well
do you think he's going to win this
i would be very surprised if he doesn't
to be honest still needs a lot of hard
work
and against the queen there's always a
chance you'll lose control but anish
okay he's going on the attack now
lifting his rook up the board that's not
to bring his rook anywhere but it's to
support white's dark square bishop if
white starts square bishop can line
itself on the same diagonal as the black
queen and black king it's game over and
he can do that here as well look at the
two players they both leaned back at the
same time
and that's what happened with this move
what a move what a finish giving up the
white bishop but if the black pawn takes
this bishop now then the white rook on
the g file is free to go up to the top
of the board and trap the black king
prague is shaking his head came over
yeah he knows it's over there's nothing
to do he has to give up his queen
very nice game for me i have to say
because i mean even though the computer
said that prague's position was always
okay i think we all agreed that anisha's
position was better throughout and he
just kept the pressure on two bishops
won the game
and it's over